[Applause]
that's when I started playing this
role
I was very young I don't have this
beard and I had to
whiten my temples to look
older
now it's not worth it anymore I have
the age of the role
[Music]
[Applause]
my name is ditch rejection i'm a
comedian the play we're
doing is called the bald singer the first time i played this character which was in 1958 it's been
60 years  i think it can be pointed out
because it has never happened in
any theater on this planet so
i play the role of mr smith
it is about a couple mr and mrs
smith who are going to receive
friends who  is called monsieur and madame
martin
for having played this show for so
many years the character of monsieur swiss
that i interpret has become a great friend
i live with him will say same day and mrs
lee
after six thousand performances from
me we could  believe
I got bored and well no
I  always plays exact fact with a
lot of enthusiasm and a lot of
pleasure
yes there will come a day when I will
have to give up this role but it will be
a pang in my heart
[Music]